I am not presenting my identity card because you,
Mr. Policeman,
cannot withhold my identity card.
I am not presenting my card because as a citizen
I am simply obliged to show you my identity card.
This is an argument used by many people in order not to
identify themselves to the police authority that demands it.
Three number one questions arise from this approach: is the citizen correct?
Number two the policeman if he requires a ID card to identify
himself a person is incurring a disciplinary offense for
allegedly withholding the document AND number three what are
the consequences of the citizen if he does not identify himself?
The first clarification we must make is that every Argentine citizen is
obliged to identify himself or herself before the authorities that so require.
This is established in the regulation.
Which Standard?
Law 18. 0.
1 Article 35 What does the aforementioned rule say?
I would like to read it verbatim Article 35 behaviors
that affect relations between people and authorities.
Number three prevent making it difficult for police authorities to
obstruct or resist an identification or individualization procedure.
The norm is clear and this numeral three of article 35 of law 18.
0.
1 has not been repealed by any other rule Nor has it been
declared unexecutable by the constitutional court Therefore it
is in force and must be applied and the policeman is called to
apply it because that is precisely the function of the policeman.
Have you been presented with this type of procedure where you
have to deal with rude aggressive people who refuse to
identify themselves on the grounds that you cannot retain the document?
Tell me in the comments I don't know.